salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans questions aux sénateurs
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire avec
public sénat
on reçoit un sénateur une sénatrice pour
répondre à vos questions cette semaine
on a le plaisir de recevoir frédéric
marchand sénateurs la république en
marge du nord bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je vous
en prie bien installés vient d'arriver
tout va bien tout va bien tu perds on va
passer une heure ensemble on va
apprendre à vous connaître et on va
répondre aux questions qui ont été
posées par les internautes c'est vous
qui allez poser vos questions à frédéric
marchand c'est avec vous que j'ai
préparé cette émission donc j'ai
beaucoup de questions à poser bonjour à
vous si vous nous regardez là en direct
sur twitter bonjour à vous si vous ne
regardez sur public sénat le canal le
canal 13 de la tnt et bonjour aussi à
vous si vous nous écoutez en podcast on
va parler de beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui avant de parler de vous et
de faire votre portrait je voudrais
qu'on parle d'abord de l'actualité du
moment évidemment le remaniement ça fait
48 heures qu'on a un nouveau
gouvernement qui a été nommé avec
monsieur castex jean castex nouveau
premier ministre
première question qui vous est posée par
rieuse est ce que vous le connaissiez je
le connais c'est effectivement dans les
fonctions qu'il avait occupées
pour les autorités gouvernementales donc
mais j'ai à titre personnel n'ont jamais
travaillé j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
travailler avec lui mais évidemment
depuis lundi soir j'avoue que la
connaissance est plus forte
j'imagine bien c'est quoi la différence
entre castex et philippe une question de
lucas la différence entre castings et
philippe bas je pense qu'il est encore
un peu tôt pour dire quel est le style
castex donc on verra moi j'ai apprécié
de travailler avec edouard philippe qui
était un homme qui avait beaucoup
d'humour j'ai l'impression que le
nouveau premier ministre ne manque pas
non plus donc ça c'est un point commun
je reste un peu moi mais on verra non
non non non non non non non on verra pas
le même genre d'humour mais il a de
l'humour
j'ai hâte de voir ça une question qui
vous est posée par cirio qui vous
demande quid de la nomination d'après
ministre qui n'est pas parlementaire
nouveau ça quand même
c'est effectivement nouveau mais le
président de la république nous a
habitués à beaucoup de nouveautés je
pense qu'on continue sur sa droite ligne
de la nouveauté de ces une bonne
nouveauté celle là y'a pas un côté recul
du parlement présidentialisme et c'est
comme le non non je suis pas persuadé
enfin j'ai eu la chance d'être a rendu
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
et j'ai apprécié effectivement que des
citoyens puisse se saisir
je trouve que la démocratie
représentative l apal monopole du savoir
politique et le fait que de nouvelles
têtes arrivent qui ne sont pas forcément
issus du sérail ne me perturbent à titre
personnel absolument pas bon hier vous
avez déclaré à public sénat que vous
aviez été re motiver par la nomination
de jean castex rebooster rebooster vous
allez me rebooster il ya todd qui vous
demande alors qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est
ce que vous avez fait perdre votre
motivation
ab je n'avais pas du tout perdu ma
motivation non non mais ça ce sont des
propos de journalistes qui effectivement
essayé de vous entraîner sur certaines
pentes parfois savonneuse j'essaye
décernant vous avez vous essayé vous
faites bien mais un autre jeu je
trouvais c'était le sens de mon
intervention que c'était important que
la première adresse du premier ministre
soit en direction des parlementaires
et c'est vrai que se retrouver lundi
soir à matignon avec le premier ministre
pour sa première sortie officielle
ça fait du bien aux parlementaires qui
effectivement été dans une petite
période de doute ai-je envie de dire
même si le doute s'est pas forcément
ceux qui habitent le plus les sénateurs
votre collègue la sénatrice laurence
rossignol sénatrice socialiste a déclaré
que ce gouvernement était une gifle pour
les femmes
fait référence notamment à la nomination
de gérald darmanin au poste de ministre
de l'intérieur et d'eric dupond-moretti
au poste de ministre de la justice
tous les deux ayant eu des positions par
le passé hostile aux droits des femmes
selon elle et gérald darmanin ayant
actuellement une affaire de viol et
d'agressions sexuelles en cours bat eric
dupond moretti l'a rappelé cet
après-midi la présomption d'innocence
est un sujet fort donc voilà ils ont été
tous les deux nommés ministres comme dit
l'autre wait and see je regarde un petit
peu les réactions je regarde un peu les
réactions du chat droite ligne de la
nouveauté
est-ce que c'est l'expression pour dire
que rien ne change c'est jules si vous
demande sa droite n'ont encore rien ne
change dans contraire le premier
ministre l'a rappelé on l'a vu cet après
midi lors de la séance de questions au
gouvernement
et aussi à l'assemblée nationale je
pense que c'est un gouvernement qui n'a
pas le temps de faire ses preuves qui va
être au combat tout de suite voilà il ya
des nouveaux talents qui sont arrivés il
ya effectivement des gens qui ont un
passé dans la vie politique et six qui
sont reconnus pour la qualité du travail
qu'elles ont pu faire je pense notamment
à rose-hill roselyne bachelot qui a la
culture va je l'espère rae a porté de l'
enthousiasme mais voilà la nouveauté
c'est un gouvernement de combat ce qui
est ce qu'il ya un virage dans le
quinquennat
ban a beaucoup la pression je pense à la
une de libération qui a dit on prend les
mêmes et on recommence
il ya plutôt que de parler de virage je
pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet dans notre
pays qui s'appelle la crise sanitaire et
qui va demain généré une crise
économique à nulle autre pareille
je pense que le virage il est là surtout
donc pas de changement de nom
gouvernementale on garde le cap
le premier ministre l'a dit cet après
midi mais effectivement on s'adapte aux
conditions qui vont sortir de cette
crise sanitaire et sociale avec une
volonté qui consiste toujours à réformer
le pays et à ne pas mettre de côté les
grands sujets tels qu'ils ont pu être
abordés on va parler de vous frédéric
marchand on va apprendre à vous
connaître un petit peu vous êtes juriste
de formation
oui pourquoi des études de droit vous
aviez vous sur le droit c'est pourquoi
des études de droit à la base je voulais
être journaliste sportif
oui oui je voulais être journaliste
sportif
quand je me rase et non à l'époque je ne
me rase et pas il m'arrivait de me dire
que j'aurais m président de la
république mais finalement je n'aimerais
absolument plus mais voilà pile à la
chose politique m'a toujours intéressée
et donc la filière droit avec tout ce
qui tournait autour du droit
constitutionnel du droit public les
sciences politiques me passionner alors
juste journaliste sportif vous faites du
sport vous êtes passionné de sport j'ai
fait du sport dans ma tendre enfance ils
ont fait beaucoup moins maintenant
j'essaie d'entretenir ma forme mais ça
c'est évident c'est quoi je joue au foot
j'ai joué au rugby mais beaucoup de ce
qui est beaucoup de ski pour un gars du
nord c'est surprenant mais c'est comme
ça et pas osé le dire vous avez dit donc
la politique c'est ça a été votre truc
très tôt vous avez adhéré au parti
socialiste à 23 ans si je ne me trompe
pas je pense même avoir adhéré plus
jeune je pense que j'ai adhéré à 19 ans
parti socialiste il avait alors crié
alors ok pourquoi est-ce qu'on adhère au
parti socialiste à 19 ans dans le vallon
là vers parti socialiste c'est la
théorie de la reproduction cher à pierre
bourdieu on adhère au parti socialiste
parce qu'on est dans une famille
d'enseignants où on parle beaucoup
politique où effectivement vous avez un
moment fort dans une vie qui est le 10
mai 81 et l'élection de françois
mitterrand à la présidence de la
république donc quand vous bercer dans
ces choses là et quand vous même vous
êtes animé de ses idéaux à un moment
donné vous franchissez le pas et vous y
allez
je sais qu'en 2002
étrangement la question est ce que vous
comprenez les jeunes qui aujourd'hui ne
sont plus du tout attirée par l'adhésion
à un parti politique
je pense qu'ils sont plus forcément
attirés par l'adhésion d'un parti
politique à partir du moment où le champ
politique c'est terriblement élargie
vers d'autres organisations que les
seules organisations politiques
c'est une grande nouvelle chose alors
moi titre personnel je trouve c'est une
bonne chose je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose qu'on s'occupe de politique
au sens noble du terme dans tout un tas
d'organisation quand on est sur les
questions d'environnement on fait de la
politique quand on est sur les questions
de précarité alimentaire
on fait de la politique va quand on
s'engage on fait de la politique vous
avez été assistant parlementaire de
bernard derosier ça rapidement vous avez
découvert du coup la politique du côté
travailleur cesser plus dense et plus
compliqué que ça il se trouve que
j'étais à la fac de droit dans une
association qui a un peu fait parler
d'elle à l'époque qui s'appelait le
cactus puisque cette association
iconoclaste de joyeux drilles organiser
des conférences débats avec eux des élus
venus de tous horizons et donc moi il se
trouve que l'on m'avait chargé à
l'époque d'organiser compte tenu d un
coin temps ce que je pouvais avoir une
conférence débat avec le président du
conseil général de l'époque kate et
bernard derosier sur le thème de la
décentralisation et qu'à la fin de cette
conférence qui s'était fort bien passé
bernard derosier me dit est ce que tu ne
connaîtraient pas un étudiant qui est en
fin de cursus
car je recherche un assistant
parlementaire je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit qu'à la fac
en s'organisant un peu vent pouvait à la
fois concilier vie universitaire et vie
professionnelle et donc comme on n'est
jamais aussi bien servi que par soi même
j'ai mis ma candidature sera la taille
c'est vrai voilà comment ça concerne
aussi accumulé les deux où c'était
impossible
si si ça a été mais arrivé en 2e c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué de parler si
vous avez été directeur de cabinet du
maire du rocha du maire de ronchin en
ouais il ya pas mal de personnes qui ne
savent pas ce que c'est qu'un directeur
de cabinet comme boulot son directeur de
cabinet c'est celui qui organise la vie
politique en l'occurrence du maire les
prises de rendez-vous les liaisons avec
la partie administrative de la mairie le
secrétariat général de la mairie les
services administratifs quelques
relations avec le monde économique avec
la société civile bref c'est celui
facilitent la vie quotidienne de lumière
vous avez ensuite été élu je vous avais
été lu notamment au conseil municipal de
lille avec pierre mauroy à l'époque et
par la suite réélu en 2001 et la adjoint
à la maire martine aubry une question
qui vous est posée par cirio vous
souteniez aubry depuis toujours
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
municipales de lille je soutenais
effectivement martine aubry pas depuis
toujours puisque vous l'avez dit moi
j'ai commencé ma carrière avec un homme
qui pour moi reste le summum en termes
impressionnant quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
fait pour la ville de lille qui a
beaucoup fait pour le nord et pour la
région c'est pierre mauroy qui au
panthéon des hommes politiques est loin
devant donc pierre mauroy n'étant plus
maire de lille effectivement je me suis
retrouvé aux côtés de martine aubry et
pour revenir à la situation de
l'élection municipale
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé un peu
partout en france moi je faisais le
parallèle entre cette élection
municipale et ce fabuleux documentaire
sur netflix
alors martine aubry n'est pas michael
jordan mais j'y voyais nanterre sur
netflix la dernière danse the last dance
pour les initiés donc où le retour de
michael jordan pour son dernier titre de
nba et donc je comparais cette
trajectoire de martine aubry à celle de
marc jordan puisque c'est son dernier
combat politique
et voilà le dernier combat politique
aurait pu mal se terminer mais je pense
que s'il s'était mal terminée n'ont eu
qu'à s'en prendre à elle-même
d'accord vous avez adhéré à la
république en marchant tonique ça vous
idée la création
oui pourquoi j'ai adhéré à la république
en marche je pense que pour tout vous
dire je ne me sentais plus en adéquation
avec les tests qui étaient portés par
mon parti au niveau national par ma
formation politique et puisqu'on parle
de martine aubry
je ne me sentais plus du tout en
adéquation avec la façon de travailler
du maire de lille très autoritaire très
clanique très solitaire et j'ai comme
beaucoup d'ailleurs découvert un livre
qui s'appelait révolution à l'époque et
j'avoue que révolution a été une
révélation
et donc après j'ai eu un parcours
classique qui m'a consiste à un livre
écrit par le fameux livre écrit par
emmanuel macron et des propos sur la
laïcité sur l'éducation qui est un sujet
étant maire d'hellemmes avec un quartier
situé en politique de la ville qui me
perturbe intéressé au plus haut point et
donc je me suis vraiment retrouvé
j'avais besoin d'un nouvel horizon
emmanuel macron m'a donné ce nouvel
horizon
vous avez été élu sénateur en 2017
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser ce
que c'est qu'être
marcheurs pour vous c'est quoi être en
marche pas alors ça veut dire quoi parce
que politiquement c'est pas simple c'est
pas simple c'est sarah côté disruptif
comme j'aime à le dire d'ailleurs dans
les repas ça fait donc ça ça fait un peu
cultivé disruptif non marcheurs voilà
moi mon ouvrage de référence reste
révolution marcheurs c'est avoir une
vision de la france une idée de la
france qui est basée sur comment dire le
partage de partage d énergie il partage
du savoir le partage des chances et
faire abstraction de ce que j'ai trop
vécu ces petits combats entre la droite
et la gauche parce qu'on est de gauche
on va s'opposer aux gags droite et parce
qu'on est de droite on va s'opposer aux
gars de gauche
moi je vois au sénat dans la commission
à laquelle j'appartiens qu'on a beau est
de gauche et droite on est en capacité
de se rassembler et travailler sur des
sujets qui nous sont communs pour moi
être marcheurs ce marcheur c'est ça il
ya quelqu'un qui vous demande c'est un
peu le messie emmanuel macron non c'est
pas c'est pas le messie emmanuel macron
mais nous par l'état un peu comme d'une
révélation cc oui ou gérer son livre ça
une révélation parce que j'étais arrivé
à un moment de ma vie élu local comment
bien un membre d'un parti politique ou
voilà je n'avais plus de raisons j'avais
jugé j'avais plus de frissons pour
parler simplement voilà je n'ai plus la
grinta
la question qui vous est posée par
despres ces caisses qui a évolué depuis
2016 attention à votre adhésion
vous avez évolué dans votre adhésion en
marche vous disiez vous avez parlé de fa
vous venez dire justement vous avez plus
frisson vous l'avez toujours j'ai
toujours effectivement ce frisson et ce
sentiment que notre pays il a besoin de
bouger on a besoin de bouger les lignes
la nomination d'eric dupond-moretti je
pense à la justice
c'est un symbole fort de la nécessité de
bouger les lignes dans un univers
judiciaire voilà qui reste très très
compliqué après voilà moi je suis je
suis marcheurs mais je suis animé par
l'idéal j'aurais siens faut aller vers
l'idéal mais comprendre le réel et c'est
vrai qu'entre l'idéal et le réel il ya
parfois des difficultés dans notre pays
président de la république par les
d'irréductibles gaulois c'est compliqué
de réformer dans notre pays c'est
compliqué ça c'était plus possible au
parti socialiste
non je mets pas ce que vous en faites
vous avez été déçu du début du
quinquennat françois hollande il ya un
truc qui s'est mal passé 1
j'ai été effectivement déçu du
quinquennat de françois hollande à
partir du moment où
j'avais le sentiment qu'il y avait plus
de capitaine y avait plus de cap il y
avait plus de boussole
ça partait à vau l'eau ça parte à vau
l'eau et je regrette effectivement que
bon j'ai entendu encore cet après-midi
dans la bouche du président du groupe
socialiste
le seul fait d'armes du parti socialiste
mais ça ne changera pas et ça ne
changera plus je pense malheureusement
pour ce parti c'est de se dire on a
gagné les municipales
or moi je veux bien mais le parti
socialiste il n'a pas gagné les
élections municipales la république en
marche s'est pris une volée de bois vert
ça c'est clair
mais de là à dire que parti socialiste a
gagné les municipales voilà donc c'est
sur ses certitudes et cette absence de
drogue de réflexion cette absence
d'horizon et cette absence de
perspective qui moi me lasser
véritablement autant beaucoup de gens
font une continuité entre manuel valls
et emmanuel macron il ya quelque chose
de vraiment une rupture en 2017 pour
vous entre un ancien monde le nouveau
oui il ya une vraie rupture je vous dis
que j'y retrouvais dans le livre de
d'emmanuel à mâcon que j'ai retrouvé
aussi et surtout et j'en suis pas peu
fier dans la venue du candidat macro le
premier déplacement du candidat macron
c'est dans le nord c'est à lille il
vient chez moi
il vient hellemmes je suis mère donc
voilà ça m'a valu d'ailleurs une
inimitiés féroces qui reste d'ailleurs
de la part de mes anciens entre
guillemets camarades socialistes qu'ils
me considèrent comme un traître et qui
s'ils pouvaient me mettre dans un baril
de pétrole et manduel de plume le ferai
bien volontiers mais ce jour là un
candidat est arrivé avec une vision sur
l'école sur l'école de la république qui
moi m'a emballé et je peux vous dire que
ça a été partagée et le doublement des
le dédoublement des classes en zone rép
voilà je sais d'où ça vient ce genre de
choses vous avez parlé du nord
précisément il est amorti qui vous
demande qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
montée du front national du
rassemblement national dans ce
département dans cette région ben j'en
pense que malheureusement ça a commencé
depuis plusieurs années alors on a vu
aux élections municipales hormis le cas
du pas de calais avec bruay la buissière
où là c'est un maire issu du
rassemblement national qui est arrivé
que finalement dans bon nombre de
conseils municipaux c'est le cas à lille
par exemple c'est le cas dans ma copine
alm le rassemblement national a
complètement disparu des radars dominici
pas le niveau municipal
non non c'est pas un bon millésime pour
le rassemblement national
s'agissant des élections municipales
dans nombre de communes ils ont disparu
et c'est tant mieux d'ailleurs
blabla qui vous demande le nord étant le
département le plus peuplé
essentiellement de jeunes hors ile de
france
comment voyez vous l'évolution de ce
territoire dans les 15 prochaines années
c'est un territoire qui est en résidence
permanente c'est un territoire qui a un
tas de potentiel que je sillonne du
dunkerquois à l'avesnois c'est un
grenier d'abondance en matière agricole
alimentaire
c'est un commandé un terrain d'éclosion
pour tout un tas de start up avec
euratechnologies mais pas que c'est en
matière de transition écologique avec la
ville de dunkerque eu tout un show tout
un tas de choses qui sont faites
c'est un département transfrontalier
avec la belgique à côté donc elle a
aussi des coopérations donc moi j'ai
envie de dire et je dis souvent le nord
c'est the place to be
je regarde je regarde un peu ce que vous
disent le changement s'est pas encore
maintenant un peu ce que dit le chat
pour le coup d'accord il ya pas mal de
yamal le débat justement sur l'arrivée
de macron
[Musique]
ah tiens y'a quelqu'un qui demande aux
raisons de votre pin's alors mon pin's
en fait ouais y'a plein de collègues
sénateurs qui me demandait ce sont les
17 objectifs de développement durable
puisque les eaux d'aider les fameuses au
d'aidé dont on devrait davantage parler
d'ailleurs à dakar 11 ans du coup
séquano d'aidé pour ceux qui passaient
alors les eaux d'aider ses objectifs de
développement durable ce sont des
objectifs qui ont été signés en 2015 en
septembre 2015 à new york à l'onu par
143 pays qui fondent ce qu'on appelle
l'agenda 2030 avec 169 cibles en matière
de ce qu'on va appeler pour faire simple
de transition écologique et solidaire
c'est par exemple en matière d'économie
circulaire aller plus loin qu'on le fait
en matière de pauvreté en matière de
coopération décentralisée
donc c'est vraiment une liste de cent
soixante neuf cibles qu'il faut
atteindre d'ici 2030 vous êtes devenu
sénateur en 2017 comme je disais tout à
l'heure comment êtes vous devenu
sénateur comment ça s'est passé en fait
la marche chez marshall qui vous
demander ce que vous rêviez de devenir
sénateur quand vous étiez petit alors
pour vous dire des choses je ne rêvais
absolument pas de devenir sénateur
c'est rare qu'on rêve de devenir
sénateur finalement depuis que je suis
sénateur je me dis que j'aurais
peut-être dû y penser avant mais non non
non je ne rêve est absolument pas d'être
sénateur et c'est un concours de
circonstances qui ont fait que j'ai mené
une campagne éclair puisque j'ai été
officiellement été désigné le 1er
septembre de l'année 2014 pour des
élections sénatoriales qui se déroulait
le 24 septembre 2010 est de 8 17 mars à
l'horizon 2017
donc vous avez été désigné tête de liste
la république en marchant de me le 1er
septembre les élections le 24 donc vous
imaginez le peu de temps pour faire
campagne en c'est quoi une campagne
sénatoriale du coup alors une campagne
sénatoriale par une campagne sénatoriale
une fois qu'on est élu sénateur c'est
tous les jours aller voir les maires
donc là avec les nouveaux maires élus
c'est ce qui va se passer mais là en
trois semaines
eh bien d'abord la difficulté c'était
que une campagne sénatoriale pour les
partis dits classiques est un peu plus
facile parce que vous savez le nombre de
grands électeurs qui vont voter vous
or là avec l'estampillé la république en
marche c'est un peu compliqué puisque
des élus déclaré la reine il y en avait
pas forcément beau cadeau donc il a
fallu ciblées
le département j'ai été très
utilitariste en allant sur les
territoires sur lesquels il me semblait
que j'allais pouvoir avoir un peu de
succès et un certain succès d estime et
sa pas trop mal marché
faut croire vous êtes arrivé au sénat
donc une question d'un tel tom sait
comment est ce que vous faisiez le fait
d'être un sénateur qui soutient un
gouvernement alors que l'assemblée le
sénat est majoritairement tenus par
l'opposition
ça n'est pas tous les jours facile ça
n'est pas tous les jours facile alors si
vous êtes minoritaires du coup ça nous
laisse les gens ça nous sommes
effectivement minoritaires au sénat et à
chaque fois que nous prenons la parole
nous sommes considérés comme les porte
parole officiels du président de la
république or nous avons quand même
montré à plusieurs reprises dans le
cadre de nombre de textes de lois que
voilà certes nous appartenions la
majorité présidentielle mais que nous
avions aussi nos façons de penser nos
idées arrêtées et notre liberté surtout
ça qui est très important liberté de
pensée et liberté d'agir au sein du
groupe une question qui vous est posée
par blake cas est ce que le sénateur est
en marche c'est un métier d'avenir
sénateurs en marche est ce que c'est un
métier d'avenir d'abord est ce que c'est
un métier c'est une bonne question d'un
mandat voilà c'est un mandat et c'est un
mandat effectivement bon quand on voit
certes les résultats électoraux ont pas
été mirobolants pour la république en
marche mais je comprends le département
du nord
on a quand même un vivier d'élus locaux
qui sont là aujourd'hui donc moi je me
dis que healy a matière à prospérer
on verra on verra exactement on verra
quelle est la position la république en
marche sur le sénat en tant
qu'institution la réforme du sénat
ça avait été proposé par emmanuel macron
dans certaines affaires en concept est
effectivement dans la réforme
constitutionnelle au sein de la maison
ça se passe comment cette au sein de la
maison effectivement c'était sujet à
questions et la réflexion mais bon le
processus aujourd'hui en vie d'hier
n'est plus au dessus de la pile donc là
aussi attendons et nous verrons en
fonction de ce qui se passera est ce que
le sénat est une vieille institution a
dépoussiéré ou ce qui est ce qu'il ya
vraiment quelque chose à faire pourrir
les choses le sénat vieille institution
c'est un peu l'image que j'en avais
avant d'y rentrer dre ça a changé pour
vendre mais alors ma perception ma
vision du sénat ont radicalement changé
depuis effectivement que je me suis
retrouvée je trouve que c'est une
chambre dans laquelle la rolls les
relations sont pacifiés dans lesquels on
n'est pas dans l'immédiateté on n'est
pas par exemple nos questions au
gouvernement qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale où là l'objectif c'est la
punchline
la petite phrase qui fait qu'on va
passer sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision on est une chambre qui
effectivement prend le temps de
réfléchir et dans le contrôle de
l'action gouvernementale et dans la
proposition loi et dans les commissions
dans l'émission d'information et je vous
avoue que c'est diablement intéressant
ce qui se passe au sénat on va parler on
va parler du positionnement du
positionnement du gouvernement jean
castex donc le premier le premier
ministre se revendique gaulliste social
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ce truc
là
gaulliste social là bas il faut
replonger dans notre histoire commune et
ça parce que c'est pourquoi beaucoup de
jeunes qui me regardent vous avoue que
de gaulle c'est plutôt dans les livres
d'histoire que de gaulle cette histoire
même si là je vous recommande alors tous
les jeunes et moins jeunes qui nous
écoutent
on a droit de faire un peu de pub sur la
selle sur alice bien sûr qu'ils sont
faits à la maison glénat et sa fabuleuse
collection sur les grands hommes donc il
a qui va sortir au mois de novembre qui
vient de sortir le deuxième tome puisque
c'est l'année de gaulle cette année
qu'elle est à lille 1 d'ailleurs donc
c'est l'année de gaulle et donc les
trois tomes de la bd fait en lien avec
des historiens sorte
et effectivement ça permet de découvrir
le personnage du général de gaulle qui
effectivement avait une idée de la
france
une idée très forte de la france et du
positionnement de la france dans le
monde et dans l'europe mais une vision
très social de la france donc avec des
concepts comme la redistribution la
participation
ce genre de choses vous comprenez quand
même que ça fasse énormément bizarre
pour pour des idées pour des jeunes des
citoyens d'entendre des responsables
politiques se réclamer du gaullisme en
2020 un premier ministre qui dit je suis
gaulliste cinq en tout cas je me définis
comme un gaulliste social vocaux qui
disent mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en 2020 ouais moi j'ai un fils qui va
avoir 15 ans quand vous lui parlez du
général de gaulle ça lui parle
voilà je pense que le général de gaulle
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est une
incarnation de la france c'est l'esprit
français c'est pas pour rien qu
effectivement il ya autant de gens qui
se rendent à colombey-les-deux-églises
et que voilà je veux dire l'année de
gaulle c'est pas c'est pas non plus
anecdotique donc se revendiquer du
général de gaulle comme d'autres se
revendique aujourd'hui voilà chez les
socialistes on se revendique encore de
jules guesde où les gens jaurès vous
avez fait d'ailleurs exactement
exactement une question qui avait été
posée tout à l'heure c'est est il
nécessaire de revoir nos institutions de
fond en comble la vème république est
elle un peu à bout de souffle
ouais ça c'est ça c'est un débat c'est
est un marronnier ça plutôt et les
revisiter sans doute les revisiter je
pense que les institutions de la vème
république
elles ont besoin d'être en évolution
permanente en fonction de la situation
du pays
c'est vrai que la situation 2020 n'a
plus rien à voir avec la situation qu'on
a pu connaître ya 20 ans mais de là à
vouloir être dans le chamboule-tout
permanent ça n'apporte jamais de
stabilité
si vous pensez de l'ultra
présidentialisme la vème république
c'est la constitution qui évoluent à
elle dont second peut en vouloir à
vouloir en changer
on peut on peut vouloir en changer
effectivement mai
voilà vie plenel le rédacteur en chef de
mediapart à une tribune pour critiquer
le remaniement en disant que c'est
l'espèce de fait du prince qui tout seul
au château décide de changer de premier
ministre
indépendamment de savoir si l'assemblée
le veut ou pas etc et on a beaucoup le
sentiment quand même que l'assemblée
nationale pendant que le que la 5ème
république tourne autour du personnage
du président est-ce qu'on a un régime
trop présidentielle
je dirais pas qu'on a un régime trop
présidentielle on a un régime qui est
issue d'une constitution qui a été
écrite pour faire en sorte que le
président de la république soit le
personnage clé de l'état je regarde un
peu les commentaires jean luc mélenchon
qui propose une sixième république
oui oui faut-il passer à une sixième
parfois non mais une fois qu'on sera la
sixième pourquoi pas passer à la 7è donc
ses valises
je pense qu'aujourd'hui en 2020 et avec
le moment qu'on vit on a d'autres sujets
imaginer que de revisiter la
constitution qu'on puisse y faire des
ajouts comme par exemple le propose la
convention citoyenne sur le climat très
bien et faire en sorte que la transition
écologique et voilà ce soient intégrés
dans le texte constitutionnel
moi j'y vois aucun inconvénient mais
vouloir le grand chamboule tout
j'en vois pas l'utilité je regarde un
petit peu effectivement peut-on peut-on
réellement se satisfaire de quelques
changements ou doit-on faire un
changement radical de constitution c'est
quoi la priorité aujourd'hui dans notre
pays c'est changer la constitution ou
c'est de se dire comment on va passer
les écueils et les nuages noirs là qui
s'amoncellent et ne sont pas
antinomiques
les deux sont pas antinomiques mais ces
journées donc 24 heures les semaines
donc sept jours et les énergies je pense
qu'il faut qu'elles soient mobilisés
allez demander aujourd'hui puisqu'on
parlait du département du nord allez
demander aux pme du département du nord
ce qu'elle préfère aujourd'hui allez
demander aux restaurateurs du
département du nord ce qui préfèrent le
la république a systématiquement changer
de régime à des moments de crise la 5ème
république est née dans une crise
peut-être que la 6e naîtra de la crise
qu'ont entendu il ya aussi la question
de la participation des citoyens on n'en
a pas parlé mais à l'occasion des
municipales quand même le l'abstention
est très important vous la sentez la
défiance des citoyens vis-à-vis de les
institutions de la démocratie
représentative
la défiance des citoyens elle ne date
pas de ces élections municipales je
pense que ce millésime 2020 des
élections municipales il est tout à fait
exceptionnel au regard de la situation
sanitaire et des alertes du premier tour
qui ont effectivement conduit nombre de
personnes à rester chez elle et le laps
de temps qui s'est écoulé entre le
premier et deuxième tours donc je suis
pas sûr qu'il faille regarder les
élections municipales en termes de
défiance citoyenne sous le prisme
sociologie politique il faut vraiment
intégré la crise militaire après faut
pas se raconter d'histoires la défiance
le regard de plus en plus éloignés il
est là et donc tout ce qui permettra de
favoriser les mécanismes de démocratie
participative doit être fait on continue
sur sur la question du gaullisme c'est
une question de ta robe qui vous fait
remarquer que c'est l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance de l'algérie s'est il ya
trois jours et ça aussi en tant que
gaulliste c'est quelque chose que vous
je suis pas gaulliste mois n'ont pas de
fuser moi pardon pardon le gouvernement
les gens qui se réclament du gaullisme
du gaullisme social s'inscrivent dans
cette dans cette histoire-là de la
décolonisation aussi bas ça peut nous
faire ripé sur un deuxième sur un autre
sujet en fait c'est ce que disent
edouard philippe et j'avais beaucoup
apprécié ce qu'ils disent et par rapport
à la période qu'on a vécu avec les
statuts des boulonnais les actions la
question sur canal et ses statuts tagué
l'histoire de notre pays
elle est comme envers lé fait de beaux
moments et de moins bons moments mais il
faut qu'on la prenne tel quel l'histoire
de notre pays
voilà on n'est pas obligé d'en brasser
chacun des moments de son nom on n'est
pas obligé d'en brasser chacun des
moments de notre histoire nationale mais
faut pas se raconter d'histoires on
vient de loin on vient de là où on vient
après il faut expliquer expliquer
expliquer expliquer encore à lille on a
un sujet avec la statue du général
faidherbe qui fait l'objet régulièrement
de vandalisme la maire de lille après
une bonne initiation maison pour ceux
qui nous regardent pas pour des raisons
qu effectivement le général faidherbe
qui a été un héros en 1871 a été aussi
celui qui au sénégal a usé de méthodes
plus que douteuses en réprimant de façon
plus que horribles sur place donc voilà
mais c'est l'explication je pense que
voilà plutôt que d'être tout de suite on
vilipende on vilipende environ casse
expliquons expliquant d'où nous venons
expliquons qui nous sommes
on peut aussi faire des gestes
politiques forts en lien avec
l'actualité le président algérien
demande que la france s'excuse pour la
colonisation
la france doit-elle s'excuser pour la
colonisation de l'algérie c'est un sujet
qui mérite qu'on y réfléchisse je pense
que le président macro s'est déjà
exprimé sur le sujet
c'est que c'est compliqué mais ça
participe effectivement de ce sentiment
aujourd'hui qui est que comme on est
dans l'immédiateté
comme on est dans l'image permanente on
en est aussi dans parfois dans des
schémas très très réducteur sur la
colonisation de l'algérie là je vous
avoue que c'est une excellente question
que je vous remercie de m'avoir posé ses
ouïes le voilà c'est que c'est compliqué
mais parce que l'excusé jacques chirac
en 1995 avait reconnu la participation
de l'état dans la déportation des juifs
de france pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ce qui était un geste fort de
mémoire du fait que la france assume la
part d'ombré de son histoire
est ce qu'on a fait toute la lumière sur
notre part d'ombré du racisme de la
colonisation de ça c'est le travail ja
c'est à la fois le travail des
historiens c'est de travailler
scientifique qui c'est un travail qui va
continuer et il continue encore et des
politiques
effectivement ce que voilà il faut pas
nier ce que nous avons été faut pas nier
ce que nous sommes
il faut expliquer expliquer encore on va
parler des élections municipales avec
vous est ce que c'est une question qui
vous est posée spa qui vous est posée
par redore qui vous demande suite aux
résultats des municipales et au
changement de gouvernement
la république en marche n'est-elle pas
en train d'abandonner sa frange sociale
démocrate au profit d'europe écologie
les verts est une part de l'électorat
qui a été séduit par la pluie vent
marche en 2017 qui maintenant fils du
côté d'europe écologie les verts par
déception aussi du métro nisme je pense
qu'effectivement à gauche il ya une
partie des gens qui avaient voté pour
emmanuel macron en 2017 qui ont voté
pour europe ecologie les verts qui
avaient une offre en matière de
transition écologique clairement
affichée avec des intentions claires
nettes et précises d'accord donc c est c
est une déception du de la politique
écologique menée par le gouvernement a
pas une déception de la politique
écologique mais peut-être l'occasion de
se dire ça y est localement parlant on
va être sur des terrains
d'expérimentation on va y aller plus
vite on va y aller plus fort donc
allons-y apportons nous suffrages au
vert moi je ne fais pas partie de celles
et ceux qui font du verre bashing je
considère au contraire bon notamment à
lille pour avoir échangé avec eux qu'il
ya il ya de bonnes idées qu'on peut se
rejoindre et qu'on peut travailler
ensemble sur
tel ou tel sujet on avait même parlé
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale au
début du confinement dans celle en ce
moment politique un peu particulier vous
pensez qu'on aurait pu avoir un
gouvernement avec les écoles je pense
qu'on aurait pu mais on en revient au
début de notre conversation sur les
partis politiques et les vieux réflexes
des partis politiques n'oublions pas que
nous sommes à deux ans d'une élection
présidentielle
et on imagine mal tel ou tel même si
forcément il envie de se mettre au
service de son pays d'aller brûler ses
cartouches trop vite on croyait qu'il ya
l'opportunisme dans la part d'un certain
nombre d'opposants non c'est pas de
l'opportunisme mais c'est de se dire
voilà dans deux ans il ya le graal
l'élection présidentielle donc faisons
attention ce que nous allons faire
restons sur notre posture c'est aussi ce
que je dénonçais dans ma formation
politique d'être vraiment sur des
postures voyons un petit peu vos
réactions sur le chat se sauver en pas
bien faut prendre la république en
marche comme une partie sur le
libéralisme et sur quoi d'autre
la fmh est il un parti libéral ça dépend
la définition qu'on veut donner au mot
libéral parisse mais conomique pro
business pour le recul de l'état et des
esses des prélèvements obligatoires
suppression du recul de l'état non et
d'ailleurs on vit dans une période où
jamais les robinets n'ont été aussi
ouvert de la part de l'état d'ailleurs
ça me fait doucement rigoler quand je
vois que bon nombre de gens disent
encore c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux
l'état ne fait rien sauf que quand vous
êtes aux états unis je regardais ce midi
les informations en israël où la france
a été citée en exemple pour le fait
d'avoir été aux secours tout
naturellement d'ailleurs de nombreux
artisans et nombre de pme non non non
c'est plutôt le libéralisme de la pensée
j'ai envie de dire qu un libéralisme
économique
c'est de se dire que tout le monde tout
le monde peut réussir tout le monde peut
s'en sortir encore faut-il qu'on lui en
donne les moyens
moi c'est comme ça que le vix ce matin
la députée virginie duby muller pour les
républicains à à taxer le gouvernement
de jean castex d'être un gouvernement
trop à gauche rapport à ceux précisément
ce que vous êtes en train de dire un
gouvernement qui va laisser filer les
déficits qui va dépenser sans compter
qu'ils ne va rien maîtriser etc
qu'est ce que pensait cette analyse qui
est porté par un public je trouve que
c'est une analyse à courte vue il est
toujours facile de critiquer quand on
est dans l'opposition à linverse si le
gouvernement n'avait rien fait on lui
reprochait de n'avoir rien fait donc
voilà je considère que la les outils qui
ont été utilisés par le gouvernement ont
permis d'amortir on voit qu'il ya des
indicateurs qui repartent à la hausse
la fréquentation des restaurants est en
train de repartir à la hausse les offres
d'emploi dans mon département sont en
train de repartir à la hausse alors faut
pas se raconter d'histoires la situation
qui arrive va être compliqué mais au
moins cette espèce d'amortisseur a
permis d'éviter une catastrophe
immédiate qu'est-ce qui vous demandaient
ce que la montée des écologistes aura un
impact sur les sénatoriales il se peut
effectivement que quelques sénateur
écolo arrive
au sénat puisque avec des villes comme
bordeaux des villes comme strasbourg des
vies comme
marseille des villes comme lyon bien
évidemment ça peut avoir quelques
conséquences en terme de grands
électeurs
est ce que vous pensez qu'un groupe
écolo au sénat est possible à nouveau on
en parle on en parle on en parle dans
les travées sénatoriales ce serait une
bonne chose pour le sénat ça serait
effectivement une bonne chose que
d'avoir ce regard vert au sénat lorsque
vous est ce que vous nous rappeler
combien de sénateur il faut pour créer
un groupe
si ma mémoire est bonne je pense que
c'est une dizaine et qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un groupe pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est quoi un groupe
sénatorial alors un groupe sénatorial
c'est un rassemblement de personnes
issues de formations politiques ou d'un
courant de pensée ou parfois même qu'ils
sont pas issus de formations politiques
mais qui ont décidé de travailler
ensemble et donc à partir de là vous
bénéficiez de moyens qui vous permettent
de travailler au quotidien quand vous
êtes sénateur le poids des départements
ruraux et plus important au sénat
baptiste qui fêtera qui fait référence à
ces vrais ondes ils ont dit que le sénat
c'est la chambre de la ruralité
donc moi j'ai nombre de collègues qui
effectivement sont issus des territoires
ruraux et à titre personnages sont
justement très enrichissant cette
confrontation entre les sénateurs issus
des métropoles et les sénateurs et sur
des territoires plus ruraux moi je viens
d'un département vous avez la métropole
européenne de lille donc si c'est un
département très rural donc ça permet de
parler un peu au nom de tout le monde
une question de deux musiciens qui vous
demandent comment voyez-vous le cumul
des mandats du maire de tourcoing le
gérald darmanin qui est en même temps
ministre de l'intérieur c'est une
décision qui lui appartient j'ai envie
de dire vers une opinion dessus offre
une opinion de ce oui oui si si je peux
effectivement avoir une opinion sur le
sujet ministre de l'intérieur c'est un
job qui occupe beaucoup beaucoup
après gérald darmanin
est une bête de travail donc
le fait d'être ministre de budget et de
mener à bien les différentes réformes ne
l'ont pas empêché non plus d'avoir un
regard aiguisé sur la ville de tourcoing
donc à suivre
et quand même d'être maire de tourcoing
ministre de l'intérieur ouais c'est
compliqué non non je conçois
effectivement que c'est compliqué donc
c'est à lui de choisir str reste ont pas
élus locaux parce que oui parce que je
pense que ça en temps je pense que c'est
important pour un ministre d'avoir un
ancrage territorial
après effectivement la règle qui veut
que quand on est ministre on ne peut
plus être maire voilà donc là aussi
attendons et voyons
eh bien écoutez on est on attendra et on
verra on va on va qu'on va continuer sur
la question de l'écologie
la convention citoyenne pour le climat a
rendu ses travaux il ya quelques
semaines avant la bande annonce du
remaniement et avant le second tour des
élections municipales
est-ce que vous avez rencontré les
citoyens commencent alors j'ai eu la
chance d'être invité par le président de
la république l a rendue qui s'est
déroulée à l'elysée
pas ce lundi mais lundi précédent j'ai
eu effectivement l'occasion d'échanger
avec plusieurs nordistes de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat vous
avez trouvé comment eh bien écoutez je
les ai trouvés enthousiasme est alors je
vais pas discuter qu'avec des nordistes
d'ailleurs et tous tout se faisait le
même constat que il se demandait à
quelle sauce ils allaient être mangés et
ce qu'ils allaient découvrir mais qu'ils
avaient découvert tout un tas de
nouveaux horizons qu'ils avaient
découvert le fait de travailler ensemble
le fait de ne pas être d'accord et
finalement le fait d'arriver à des
propositions auxquelles ils n'auraient
jamais pensé
emmanuel macron s'était engagé à
transmettre leurs propositions sans
filtre au parlement et lors de la
présentation il a utilisé trois joker en
refusant notamment de transmettre la
limitation à 110 kilomètres d'autoroutes
la taxation des dividendes et la
troisième chose je ne sais plus la
modification du préambule de la
constitution
est-ce qu'il a trahi la promesse qu'il a
faite à la convention citoyenne a priori
non parce que pour avoir là aussi
échanger avec les membres de la
convention citoyenne j'ai pas eu
l'impression qu'ils étaient plus que ça
ému par les trois joker du président de
la république qu'ils étaient au
contraire très satisfait de voir que les
propositions allaient être transmises
sans filtre j'avais d'ailleurs été
signataire d'un courrier au président de
la république en ce sens dans la foulée
on a aussi appris que quelques nouveau
joker sortait petit à petit de certains
ministères je pense notamment à bruno le
maire qui a fait savoir qu'il était
contre l'interdiction de la publicité
pour les véhicules polluants vous pensez
qu'on va attendre au fur et à mesure de
l'examen des textes on va arriver à peau
de chagrin et toutes les propositions
des citoyens en finance je pense pas le
président de la république a été clair
donc faisons confiance au président de
la république après ça n'interdit pas
tel ou tel ministre de donner son
opinion pression mais c'est vous les
parlementaires qui avaient un rôle à
l'extérieur ce sont surtout
effectivement les parlementaires qui
vont travailler sur tous ces sujets le
fait que ces propositions via une
convention citoyenne tirés au sort est
ce que ça donne de la force à leur
composition
ou est-ce qu à l inverse je dis ça parce
que je vois les sénateurs sur le même
canapé qui sont très remontés contre je
sais et citoyenne je sais maintenant
mais nous avions auditionné dans la
commission dans laquelle je suis membre
effectivement un des co animateur de
cette convention et je peux vous dire
que l'accueil qui lui a été réservé
était assez frais plats ne pas dire
autre chose voilà glacial hu à titre
personnel c'est ce que j'ai expliqué
c'est ce que j'ai dit
et redis je pense que de la démocratie
représentative doit se nourrir de la
démocratie participative et que faut pas
vivre ça comme de la concurrence voilà
c'est pas parce que je suis sénateur que
j'ai le monopole du savoir politique et
le monopole du savoir institutionnels
non je suis désolé il ya tout un tas de
choses que je ne maîtrise pas moi j'ai
vraiment apprécié et aimé cette
appétence qu'avaient ses citoyens pour
la chose politique pour la transition
écologique et la volonté de s'engager
sur des sujets qu'ils auraient même pas
imaginé possible donc non moi je vis
absolument pas ça comme une forme de
concurrence
au contraire si c'est une façon de
renouer le lien entre nos concitoyens et
la chose politique mais allons-y
développons les convention citoyenne
dans un tas de choses d'être
probablement des premiers sénateurs qui
me disent ah ah bon ah mais c'est
impressionnant on veut vraiment oui ça
fait deux ans que j'interviewe des
sénateurs sur ce canapé précisément j'ai
toujours ressenti une frilosité pour
pour pas dire pire nos vis-à-vis de la
participation citoyenne
moi je dis ça parce que voilà des
parlementaires se sentent ont
l'impression qu'on va leur arriver sinon
oui alors il ya des parle moi j'ai
entendu des carbo collègues
parlementaires qu'ils disent oui mais
c'est trop facile
il propose des trucs on avait donc on
avait évoqué on avait fait des
propositions luanda et hertault kais ben
oui mais j'ai envie de lui dire ma pauv'
lucette c'est le jeu voilà on revient au
début d'autres conversations ou sur
cette dichotomie entre voilà parce que
l'opposition propose c'est pas bien mais
c'est pas aussi les choses ne sont pas
aussi manichéenne que ça donc le fait
que les citoyens s'emparent de ça et que
ça vienne nourrir le débat politique
mais c'est parfait c'est fabuleux
et si à l'échelon local on peut aussi
développer c'est qu'on vend si tu de ces
conventions site wenn c'est parfait moi
quand j'étais maire j'avais développé
des formes de démocratie participative
jeu regrettait amèrement alors peut-être
sans doute qu'on n'avait pas des process
aussi aboutie que ceux de la convention
citoyenne
mais je regrette amèrement qu'en matière
de démocratie participative et c'est ce
qui fait aussi que parfois on est un peu
rétif par rapport à cette chose à c'est
que quand vous vous retrouvez face à une
assemblée de citoyens vous avez des
professionnels de la parole qui
monopolisent à la fois la parole et qui
font que certains citoyens qui auraient
des choses intéressantes à dire ne
disent rien alors que la convention
citoyenne
ça a été organisé de telle façon je vous
assure les gens du nord c'était vraiment
des profils radicalement différents
entre le jeune start-up peur et la
retraitée
de l'éducation nationale et ce sont des
gens qui se sont retrouvés qui ont
travaillé ensemble et qui n'ont pas
hésité à porter leurs propositions ah
non moi je suis enthousiaste une
question de ben qui vous qui vous
demande quel est l'objectif de
d'emmanuel macro à long terme sur
l'écologie et l'économie
il plaide le fait qu'on qu'on peut
réconcilier les deux et que les deux
peuvent aller de pair et on entend de
plus en plus un discours qui est
davantage vers un modèle décroissant
triste ou en contraction
est-ce que vous pensez que l'on peut
faire par exemple de la croissance et en
même temps de l'écologie oui parce que
l'écologie justement synonyme de
croissance en termes de métiers prenons
l'agriculture et l'alimentation voix
l'alimentation durable et local qui est
un sujet qui m'est cher si aujourd'hui
on met en place une politique vraiment
novatrice en matière d'alimentation
durable et local on est en capacité de
créer un million d'emplois
c'est par la décroissance j'ai dans le
domaine de la transition écologique il
ya une des niches en matière d'emploi
qui sont absolument pas délocalisables
qui est phénoménal est formidable on
n'est pas du tout sur le champ de la
décroissance quand on parle d'écologie
ça ce discours je l' ai beaucoup entendu
dans les municipales notamment à lille
de la part de l'équipe sortante où j'ai
entendu les pires âneries par rapport au
fait que les écologistes pourraient
arriver aux plus hautes responsabilités
la droite par notamment d' écologie
punitive au sujet des propositions la
conscience humaine pour le climat baisse
de la vitesse sur l'autoroute
il ya même une des propositions pour une
baisse du temps du travail augmentation
des taxes etc
vous voyez l'écologie vous aussi comme
une forme de punition danser la taxe
carbone non pour moi l'écologie elle est
absolument pas punitive l'écologie elle
doit être partagé la vision écologie
faut arrêter de se raconter des
histoires si on continue on va dans le
mur
on avait cet après-midi un sénateur pour
ne pas le nommer laurent duplomb qui
nous a posé une question au gouvernement
qui était complètement ridicule nous
expliquant qu' un éco logis s'excuser
parce qu'il avait tenu des propos nous
indiquant que la planète allait dans le
mur mais qui s'était rendu compte que
c'était pas vrai si la planète va dans
le mur
donc il faut qu'ils aient vraiment une
prise de conscience de la part des uns
et les autres et
il faut des mesures qui soient des
mesures fortes qui soient prises mais ça
ne marchera que si c'est partagé par le
plus grand nombre
est ce que c'est un gros mot
décroissance c'est pas ta qui vous
demande ça est ce que c'est un gros mot
non mais disons que c'est un mot comme
beaucoup qui a été tellement employé que
finalement il a pris un sens qui n'est
plus forcément le sens initial
quand on parle de décroissance on
effectivement aujourd'hui sur une vision
très négative on a l'impression que les
lumières vont s'éteindre que nos
téléphones vont tomber en panne alors
que non on peut très bien vivre de
manière différente en 2020 et je lui qui
vous demandent punir un peu pour éviter
le pire est ce que ce n'est pas juste
quelque chose de logique
at il pu dire les copains punir sais pas
mais restreindre par la loi ou par les
règlements les comportements qui
polluent le plus que comme le tabac kiki
oui 6 non mais là dessus oui mais je
parle pas j'appelle pas ça de la
punition c'est pas la punition on n'est
pas dans les cauris et action réaction
j'appelle ça effectivement du bon sens
et du bon sens qui doit être partagé par
tous et partout je sais que c'est le
plus difficile
j'aimerais par les munitions prêts à
partager ça on n'y arrive pas on n'y
arrive pas je pense qu'on arrive à
quelque chose aujourd'hui c'est la
conscientisation des esprits sur ces
questions-là de la conscientisation à
l'action maintenant il faut passer à une
seconde étape est peut-être que la
convention citoyenne sur le climat ça va
permettre d'aller plus loin
vous avez de l'espoir vis-à-vis de ça de
la transformation écologique bah moi je
suis optimiste de nature mais alors je
vous avouerai que par exemple moi je me
faisais une joie pendant le confinement
de voir que tout ce qui était circuits
courts se développe et je me disais ça y
est on re découvre un nouveau mode de
consommation et je me dis et c'est là
que je l'action de l'état est importante
je revois que finalement bon nombre de
nos concitoyens alors après c'est le
rythme de la vie qui veut ça ont repris
leurs habitudes de consommation
traditionnelle alors que là aussi en
matière de transition écologique il ya
des pépites qu'il faut encourager donc
je pense que le pouvoir politique il
doit être là pour accompagner encourager
ces nouveaux modèles ou siéger au sein
de la commission de l'aménagement terry
de du territoire du développement
durable n'est pas précisé mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on parle le 6 juin dès
ce sujet là pardon
qu'est ce que vous pensez du nucléaire
question qui revient très souvent quand
on parle d'écologie l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire en france est allée
à moins polluantes
alizé elles s'imposent à tous c'est la
moins polluante c'est la moins polluante
alors après effectivement le risque le
risque est là le risque existe moi je
suis plus partisans de m comment dire le
turbo sur tout ce qui est énergie
alternative la méthanisation l'éolien le
solaire mais la réalité nucléaire elle
est là au jour d'aujourd'hui
vous pensez que barbara pompili va
réussir là où nicolas hulot a jeté l
éponge à nicolas hulot il est parti à mr
quand même en 2018 andreu très très amer
en dénonçant le poids des lobbys
l'impossibilité d'avancer à cause de
bercy nécessaire de l'agriculture etc
barbara pompili ancienne europe ecologie
les verts d'ailleurs nommé depuis hier
ministre de la transition écologique est
ce que vous pensez que là en quelques
heures
je pense que barbara pompe ils y
arrivent à un moment particulier qui
effectivement ce moment de la crise
sanitaire ou les logiciels des uns et
les autres ont pu un peu évolué le
moment où la convention citoyenne sur le
climat a rendu ses conclusions et le
moment où effectivement la question de
la transition écologique et solidaire
elle est dans tous les esprits
moi je le vois en baladant dans le
département du nord en faisant le tour
là des établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale
c'est une question qui est très très
très très présente et je pense que les
solutions viendront des territoires
c'est quoi le travail d'un sénateur
membre de cette commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable pour la transition
écologique comment ça fonctionne vos
relations avec le gouvernement vous
voter des lois pour expliquer pour ceux
qui nous regardent donc le
on accompagne effectivement dans le
cadre de l'examen des textes les projets
de loi je vais prendre deux exemples que
j'ai eu à connaître depuis 2010 est
c'est la loi d'orientation des mobilités
qui était portée par elisabeth bornes et
le gouvernement sur les mobilités du
quotidien sur lesquels nous sommes venus
abonder par notre droit d'amendement
différents dispositifs et le travail
parlementaire a vraiment été très
intenses pour arriver à un texte qui je
crois a satisfait les uns les autres le
deuxième texte sur lequel on a travaillé
c'est celui qui était portée par brune
poirson sur la lutte contre les
gaspillages et l'économie circulaire où
là aussi il ya eu de beaux débats qui
ont été organisées au sénat sur tous ces
thèmes et aussi des amendements qui ont
été portées notamment par le groupe la
république en marche on n'était pas
d'ailleurs toujours en phase avec la
ministre qui nous ont permis justement
d'avancer vers une économie davantage
circulaire donc ça c'est vraiment ça
c'est le travail législatif jeu je passe
aussi les propositions loi qui peuvent
être déposés par l'école etc sénateurs
après on a tout un travail de contrôle
de l'action gouvernementale et on a un
travail aussi avec des missions
d'information alors moins à titre
d'exemple pendant cette période de
confinement avec ma collègue nelly
tocqueville sénatrice de la seine
maritime nous avons mis en place une
mission justement sur les questions
d'alimentation durable et local qui sont
des sujets passionnants
je trouve à titre personnel que la
question alimentaire et la question
numéro un aujourd'hui dans notre pays à
la fois sous l'angle de la sécurité
alimentaire sous l'angle de la qualité
alimentaire sous l'angle de la précarité
alimentaire
bref il ya tout un tas de choses à faire
et ça me permet dans le département du
nord d'aller porter cette parole doit
avoir nombre d' échanges avec les
acteurs à la fois des acteurs de la
société civile des acteurs politiques et
de voir qu effectivement il ya tout un
tas de choses à imaginer au niveau des
territoires
et après à mettre en musique un exemple
moi je porte auprès j'en avais parlé a
dit guillaume je vais en reparler auprès
du nouveau ministre
je porte le fait que demain devait
devrait être
rendu obligatoire ce qu'on appelle des
contrats alimentaire territoriaux contre
alimentaire territoriaux durable faisant
des établissements publics des autorités
organisatrices de l'alimentation mais
non pas uniquement dans la restauration
scolaire
mais l'alimentation pour tous les
citoyens alors du coup là typiquement
vous écrivez donc un rapport donc à
dessein la mission d'information
ce rapport va porter des préconisations
conisation kid ensuite vont devenir quoi
il faut qu'ils peuvent devenir des
textes de loi qui va peuvent être repris
par le gouvernement ou qui peuvent faire
l'objet d'une proposition loi vous
trouvez que le gouvernement prête
l'oreille aux propositions des
parlementaires à leur amendement le
gouvernement est très attentif
wafa mois de franches pour depuis 2007
est un des premiers médecins
depuis c'est vrai ouais ouais ah ouais
non non moi je sais pas moi j'ai pas un
plein d'un type personnel du travail que
j'ai pu avoir tant avec elisabeth bornes
qu'avec brune poirson sur les textes
non mais je sais que c'est voilà pour la
majorité sénatoriale
c'est un peu là aussi c'est un guy mythe
que de dire que le gouvernement est
autiste le gouvernement n'écoute pas le
gouvernement ne fait pas confiance des
classes et oui mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
j'ai par contre je vais vous faire une
confidence je pense même que le
gouvernement ait beaucoup plus attentifs
à la parole qui est porté par les autres
sénateurs que par le groupe de la
république en marche
voilà ah ben on m'a parfois on est
grasse 3 qui est beau c à vous a peut
être sonné 23 donc cette fois elle fait
dire ça alors on n'est pas un groupe
charnière on n'est pas un groupe
charnière et donc c'est vrai qu'on a
parfois le sentiment au sein du groupe
la république en marche qu'on est
davantage attentifs à des paroles qui
sont portées par des collègues d'autres
groupes sont pas le groupe ait l'air
mais d'autres groupes ont peut-être un
amendement très similaires aux vôtres
déposée par un autre groupe pourrait
être adoptée par exemple mais voilà je
veux dire moi ça ça ne me perturbe pas
plus que ça j'en suis parfaitement
conscient et je trouve au contraire que
c'est le rôle du gouvernement que d'être
très attentif à ce que peuvent dire les
uns les autres
est ce que est ce qu est ce que dans le
cadre du travail du travail
d'amendements ça vous arrive de voter
des amendements venant d'autres groupes
c'est marie bové je fais partie d'un
collectif qui s'appelle au sénat le
collectif urgence climatique où on c'est
un collectif trans partisan ou là
effectivement on se retrouve
sur deux amendements communs et ça parce
que on est on est souvent habituée aux
débats à l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au
sénat qui est moins médiatisée on a
beaucoup l'impression d'une guerre de
tranchées pour le coup non nous on n'est
pas du tout sur la guerre de tranchées
ligne rouge qu'on ne franchira pas mais
il ya parfois des positions sur lesquels
on se rejoint et donc il peut faire
l'objet d'un amendement commun
les ti falic qui vous demander ce que
vous serez candidat à la présidentielle
non non non c'est fini c'est terminé
avec ça pourquoi pourquoi pas parce que
voilà c'est quoi le job de président de
la république aujourd'hui pourquoi est
ce qu'ils les parents via pourquoi
est-ce que c'est quoi c'est un enfer
c'est un sacerdoce et c'est une sacré
responsabilité
c'est une sacrée responsabilité comment
dire c'est s'exposer aux canons de
toutes et tous donc assez c'est hyper
compliqué comme boulot hyper compliqué
et membre du gouvernement pensait que
c'est similaire membres du gouvernement
c'est pas c'est pas simple non plus
c'est pas simple non plus parce que vous
avez une obligation de résultat donc la
veine obligations résultat est forcément
qui dit obligation de résultats dit gens
contents et des gens mécontents on est à
l'aube d'une potentielle crise
économique et sociale très grave
est ce que vous redoutez la rentrée de
septembre l'automne la reprise
d'éventuellement des mouvements sociaux
similaire au gilet jaune ou votre comme
beaucoup effectivement je redoute ce qui
pourrait se passer à l'automne et
notamment en terme de
fermetures d'établissements dans le
département du nord
on a déjà quelques clignotants
malheureusement qui passent au rouge
donc je pense que le gouvernement et
bruno le maire en particulier la
nomination d'alain griset est un signe
encourageant d'ailleurs pour tout ce qui
est petites entreprises le gouvernement
a bien conscience qu'il faut mettre en
place des dispositifs pour atténuer ce
qui va arriver
une question qui vient assez souvent
quand on parle de ces sujets là avec
avec les internautes c'est la question
du maintien de l'ordre de la violence
policière
est-ce que vous pensez que la manière
dont christophe castaner ancien ministre
de l'intérieur a géré le maintien de
l'ordre à l'occasion du mouvement des
gilets jaunes et de la réforme des
retraites est quelque chose de durable
est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à encore
une fois la même chose jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat je suis pas sûr qu'il faut
s'attendre à la même chose d'ici la fin
du quinquennat à partir du moment où il
ya un élément qui est passée par là qui
s'appelle la crise sanitaire et j'espère
que voilà nos concitoyens au delà du
droit de revendiquer du droit de
manifester vont comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui l'heure n'est plus à la
dispersion mais l'heure est à l'unité
c'est ce qu'a dit le premier ministre
aujourd'hui je peux comprendre que voilà
on soit en colère ont soit dépité mais
voilà l'heure est aujourd'hui à l'unité
pour éviter une casse qui pourrait avoir
des effets dévastateurs réforme de la
réforme de l'institution policière de
l'igpn la question du maintien de
l'ordre dans les manifestations le lbd
rien n'a changé là dedans s'il ya sans
doute des choses à évoluer il ya sans
doute des choses à évoluer mais arrêtons
là aussi de pointer du doigt les forces
de police par mois à titre personnel je
me rappelle de ces images de 2015 la
fameuse chanson de renaud j'ai embrassé
un flic hier cinq ans plus tard on en
est loin de lui embrasser un flic parce
que le contexte est plus tout à fait le
même est complexe et plus tout à fait le
même mais la violence s'est répandue et
la violence elle n'est pas que le
monopole de la police à la hausse il
faut arrêter de se raconter des
histoires mais si on enfin renvoyer dos
à dos en permanence manifestants
casseurs et policiers police et violence
il faut sans doute revisiter les
méthodes de la police
mais je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
stigmatiser la police qui fait un boulot
qui est pas facile
bon moi je le vois en matière moi et moi
j'ai été maire d'une commune qui était
confrontée à un phénomène s'appelle les
rodéos à moto
moi quand je discute et c'est vrai que
c'est insupportable c'est voilà la
population ne comprend pas mais quand
vous discutez avec les forces de l'ordre
il m'expliquait me disait toujours
monsieur le maire nous d'un problème
c'est qu'on peut parler poursuivre on
peut pas les poursuivre parce que si on
les poursuivre comme ce sont des têtes
brûlées
ils vont aller rouler sur les trottoirs
et vous imaginez les bavures
donc voilà il ya aussi une difficulté je
pense pour la police nationale de mener
à bien ses missions qui est pas toujours
facile
gérald darmanin donc on va en terminer
par la nouveau ministre de l'intérieur
qui arrive à la tête
donc de ce ministère dans un contexte
très difficile les policiers ont fait
des manifestations sauvages contre
christophe castaner qui leur demandait
juste d'arrêter d'étrangler les gens
vous croyez que gérald darmanin va
réussir ou même qu'il al'ambition
d'ailleurs tout simplement de de changer
la police nationale c'est bon déjà je
pense qu'il faut arrêter dire que
christophe castaner a échoué parce que
aujourd'hui
moi j il me revient aussi çà et là en
nombre de policiers qui ont salué
l'action du ministre de l'intérieur avec
gérald darmanin c'est une autre
personnalité qui arrivent place beauvau
voilà donc chacun sa personnalité je ne
sais pas
ce qui se passera mais voilà je pense
que il était maire de tours quoi il
connaît bien ces questions de sécurité
du quotidien et je ne me fais pas de
soucis sur le dialogue qui va pouvoir
être entamées par gérald darmanin avec
les forces de police
merci beaucoup frédéric marchand vous en
prie d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci à vous mais on est d'accord ça
passe très vite
ça surprend au début quand je vous dis
que ça dure une heure et en fait ça
passe très vite
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette
émission avec public sénat merci
beaucoup si vous nous avez regardé sur
twitch merci également si vous avez
regardé sur public sénat le canal 13
delà de celles de la tnt et merci à vous
si vous nous avez écouté aussi en
podcast je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine avec un prochain invité à très
bientôt ciao